hello and welcome to the third game
development with Python 3 and PI game in
this video what we're going to be doing
is building on the last off and today
what I want to do is get us to be able
to control our car because what we're
going to have this game do is we're
going to basically make it a little bit
of an avoidance game you're going to be
avoiding objects on the quote-unquote
roadway and to do that we need to be
able to swerve left or right so we want
to be able to control our little race
car that we've loaded two screens so
that's what we're going to be doing so
we're going to handle some logic here so
like I was saying before this is your
event handling loop and then you might
have a little bit of a logic loop but
for now in our event handling loop
that's going to handle all of our
movement based on user input
so if event type equals PI game got quit
crashed equals true everybody
everybody's you know good
and if crashed equals true it just ends
in a goes PI game not quit quit okay
eventually we'll change that but we're
going to have like a whole kind of game
over thing and stuff too so we'll worry
about that a little bit so we'll come
down here and it's asking basically the
first thing we ask is if it's quit then
why quit
otherwise we can also ask if event diet
type equals PI game dot and then in all
caps key down and what this is going to
ask is if there was a key press at all
like key down just means did someone
push a key down that's it if there was a
key down then we're going to say if
event dot key equals PI game dot on all
caps again K underscore left and that's
going to respond to our left arrow key
so if the event key is the left arrow
key then we want to change the location
of our car now we don't have a variable
for the location like to change the
location of the car so here we're going
to say I'm just under X&Y we can say
underscore change equals zero for now
and then we can come down here back into
our while loop and then if pygame or if
it's a left arrow then we want to move X
left right left right
I crack myself up so if we want to move
left then we want to decrease the value
of our X location right so so X is you
know on a plane and to move X well at
least for you guys I think would be this
one to move X this way we have to
subtract from the x value so we'll say X
underscore change equals negative five
when I move it um then we're going to
have L if event dot key equals PI pi
game dot K underscore right so if it's a
right key press I'm going to actually
move it we want to move it right and to
do that we would add to X so we'll say X
underscore change equals five so remove
it by five and then um the other
question that we might have is not only
do we have key down but we want to have
some sort of handling to where because
if we hold the key down it'll move it'll
move X but then if we raise our key X
change is still going to be minus five
or five so we want to be able to like
just hold it we don't want to have to
keep pressing it to make our character
move but we also want something to
happen when we release it so we need to
handle that as well
so over here where I say if event dot
type equals PI game dot and all caps key
up so if the key has been released and
it moves up what do we want to do and
let's make some space here if that is
the case then what we want to do is if
um event dot key
equals high game dot K underscore left
or event dot key equals PI game dot K
underscore right so if the key that's
being released here is either the left
or right arrow then we want to say X
underscore change equals zero we want to
make that you know zero so it doesn't
change anymore and because otherwise you
know we could have other functions like
you know you could press spacebar or
something or P for pause and stuff like
that so you know there might be other
things for now it'll the only keys that
we're gonna have in this game or left
and right anyways but just just to keep
things simple we'll do it this way and
now we want to exit everything so this
is our we're done with event handling in
in our PI game and now we want to change
variables based on the events that have
occurred so we know how much we want to
change it by what variable do we want to
change well we want to change X which is
the location right of our car because
every every frame we redraw the location
of our car so now we want to change the
value of x so we're going to say X plus
whoops plus equals x underscore change
so when it's minus five it's going to be
plus equals minus five which means we'll
subtract or if it's five it'll be plus
equals five which means it will add five
to the value of x or if it's zero it
will just plus equal zero which will do
nothing and that's it so now we're ready
to go ahead and save this and we can run
it and up pops our car pool and we can
press care arrows good moves moves left
right Wow
so much agility now the only thing
that's kind of problematic with a PI
game is if sometimes you can get like
stuck like here and I'm actually
pressing my left arrow key but for
whatever reason it is it got stuck like
you can kind of play around a little bit
but you'll get stuck sometimes so that
adds a little bit of frustration to the
game you almost have to fully lift
your key and then press over your key
and one a couple of things that you
could try to play with these options
here so for example we could do
something like this
you can remove all your LF statement so
we could save and run it again and now
you know in theory it should still run
that statement but for whatever reason
it doesn't seem to want to run mice the
other key press that's happened so in
theory if you were to press both keys at
the same time you should get a reaction
like you were pressing both at the same
time but for some reason it just doesn't
work that way or maybe you're just not
pressing at the same time I don't know
but anyway that's the only thing that
can get kind of frustrating so you
almost have to like double press a key
sometimes but you could tinker a little
bit with those to see if you could
figure out a fix so you can move clock
tick down as well as see if we can get
that to go away maybe so it still
remains no matter what what it is but as
you can see that's analogous would be a
good time talking about frames per
second so since our move is well I guess
it's 5:00 here we see the you know
changes by 5:00 we could make that
larger number and make the car move
quote/unquote faster or we could just
increase the amount of frames per second
and that also makes the car move
slightly faster so and also just for the
record the car probably looks a little
glitchy through my video I think I
normally record on like 5 or 10 frames
per second for the screen so your should
look a lot more smooth than mine is
anyway if you're following along so
that's moving the car on the screen um
pretty basic but we've got other things
that we want to add event so we're going
to add some more objects stuff like that
also we have no boundary on the car so
for example if we run this we can take
our car and we just move them on the
screen like now he's on this monitor and
we can bring him back it'll come back
eventually there it is but this is
obviously no good we want to have some
sort of boundary to the game so we can't
run into the walls like this and if we
do
we crashed or something so we're gonna
work on that as well so stay tuned for
that if you guys have any questions or
comments on this video feel free to
leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support subscriptions
until next time